طبعا هذا الحديث في هذه المحاور يمكن يطول
كثيرا فعلا
انا والاخر انت يا ابن خرط فيه مبكرا يعني
هذه المسافات الغيه لانه درست في المدرسه
يهوديه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
همم
المدرسه المدرسه
المتفقه
تفوق
وكان يوجد مدرسه اخرى
لا لا كان مدارس الا بالصدفه انا رحت لان
همم خالي كان همم يشتغل في همم هيئه الصحه
وبالتالي انها قل لي والدي لابد ان نسجل
ابنه في المدرسه يهوديه سيتعلم اشياء
كثيره واو داخلي في هذه الفتره كان هناك
مدير يهودي المعلمات والمعلمين يهود
والطلبه اليهود تلاميذ يعني لا ليس كلهم
واهم شيء انه في هذه المدرسه تعلمنا لا
يهموني ان يكون يهوديا او مسيحيين او
بوديا لا تهمل
وكنا لابد ان نقولها الاشياء كلها كان
المعلمون يدرسون على التسامح
مفهوم المحبه
في السنه اولى ابتدائي وكان في عمر ست
سنوات فضي
النقطه الاخرى كيف كان يشجعون التفوق وهذا
لم يكن في المدارس الاخرى ان التلميذ في
فرد من الفروض او واجب منزلي لما يتفوقين
اما علبه شوكولاته او علبه من الصور
الموسيقى